[Music]
wild comes to us from the director of
Dallas buyers club and stars reese
witherspoon as Cheryl Strayed the true
story of a woman who decided to take a
thousand mile hike to get over some
serious tragedies that recently occurred
in her life as a way to cleanse herself
and hopefully survive now I really like
Dallas buyers club I thought it was a
very different movie a movie that
approached storytelling in a strange way
and I really like the way they handled
it and so I was excited to see the way
he handled Wilde and Reese Witherspoon's
been an actress that I've liked for a
long time I think she's beautiful I
think she's funny she's very talented
and in this movie she gives one of the
best performances she's given in her
entire career and this movie faces a lot
of challenges for one it's a movie about
someone hiking it's really tough to make
that interesting for two hours and I
think they mostly pull it off from what
I've heard it's very true to the book
which is awesome for people who are fans
of the book but the way the movie tells
its story is that you're just in the
hike instantly like right from the
beginning she's already in it and as she
encounters various things on the way
they remind her of her past and that's
when we see flashbacks and we learn why
she is the way she is and why she's
doing what she's doing
I liked it from a filmmaking perspective
you're able to learn things about a
character as the film goes along and
it's different that way very nonlinear
but it did take a while for me to
understand why she is doing some of the
things she's doing because they hide a
lot of that for a long time which I
understand because you want to keep some
secrets about the character you want her
to be intriguing but there are times
where I just didn't feel the
significance of her journey because the
film wasn't showing us why it was so
significant to her one of the things I
loved about Reese Witherspoon's
performance is that it's totally
unglamorous there's nothing about this
role that's like look at me I'm
beautiful and lovely it's like I'm
sweaty I'm dirty my toenails are falling
off and her characters just like screw
you just shut up I want to climb this
hill just leave me alone just let me go
about my day and that's one of the
things that I loved about her character
she was intriguing but also really
likable character because she just felt
like a normal person I do have some
issues with the movie though and a lot
of them are just storytelling based like
I said it takes a while for you to
understand the significance of what
she's doing now that I've seen the movie
and I've done research on the actual
woman I know that it was very
significant to her but while you're
watching the movie from a storytelling
perspective it does take a while for you
understand why it is so important to her
what she's doing so from a directing at
a screenwriting standpoint I feel like
that's not really the wisest choice to
hide that much about your character when
your character is doing something that
seems sort of illogical it's hard to
really relate to said character when you
don't really know why they're doing it
the film is very frank about her life
for that first half and let you win on
some of the mistakes that she's made but
once you eventually do figure out what
she's been going through in her life and
how tough it's been for her you start to
understand a lot more about her
character and by the end of the film you
really care for her and you want her to
succeed it's just that for the first
half of the movie the way they decided
to tell the story made you not even
really care that much about her until
you realize just everything she's been
through so prose about while the
cinematography Reese Witherspoon's
performance you really do care about her
character once you figure things out but
the con is that you don't at first
because you're like why are you doing
this you don't know why she's doing it
and it's not as intriguing as it should
be and for that first half of the movie
it just lets you in on every mistake
that she's made in the past few years
and it makes her look kind of awful but
it does pick up and you do start to care
the performance is great the
cinematography is really good and it's
interesting in a different movie and I
like watching a person just being a
person and that's pretty cool to see in
wild so I'm going to give wild a b-minus
I do think it is a little overhyped and
then it could be a little bit better
than it was I don't think it's nearly as
good as Dallas buyers club but I do
think it's worth seeing just maybe not
at full price guys if you have seen wild
or if you read the book let me know what
you think below and as always thank you
so much for watching and if you did like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]